Welcome back everyone this will be my full
breakdown of the marvel morbius movie there's
a lot of tobey maguire andrew garfield tom holland
spider man easter eggs connections to spider man
no way home and the new sinister six movies that
they want to make so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and careful for
spoilers for the morbius movie if you haven't
seen it yet most people are talking about the
spider man no way home crossover the multiverse
connections and the post-credit scenes setting
up the sinister six movies and which version of
spider-man is going to show up in these venom
universe movies the director already clarified
that there is a spider-man that does exist in
this universe and we learned who it was pretty
soon like i said there are a lot of easter eggs
for all the different versions of spider-man so
they have their pick of the litter in terms of
which it could be i'll talk about that during the
video too morbius is an og spider-man character
that's why sony had the rights to him he appeared
in the 1970s created by roy thomas and gilkane
who do get name drops during the movie originally
marvel wanted to get into the vampire pop culture
craze back in the 70s but the rules for how
they made comics back then actually prevented
them in that era from using the traditional
horror-based vampire characters like dracula
at the time stan lee had wanted marvel's version
of dracula so that's why so much about the morbius
character makes him different than traditional
vampires like day walking and being a legit
anti-hero hating the idea of drinking human
blood the funny connection to what's happening
in the mcu now with supernatural creatures like
i'm doing moon knight episode videos right now
with a lot of supernatural characters eventually
rules and restrictions relaxed marvel was allowed
to use traditional vampire characters like
dracula dracula eventually became a blade
character he gets used a lot in the moon knight
memes as well mcu dracula is actually rumored
to be one of the villains in the new mcu
blade movie with mahershala ali next year
that's supposed to be a big team up between
marvel's new supernatural characters like
werewolf by night kit harrington's black knight
that we saw with the ebony blade and the eternals
post credit scene and it's the reason why
mahershala ali's blade is the voice that you hear
in that eternal's post credit scene kevin feige
and amy pascal said that it was possible that they
would do a blade morbius crossover it just seems
weird if they wouldn't do that eventually but the
morbius movie begins with the title sequence in
this custom version of the morbius logo his custom
logo actually uses purple similar to the colors of
his classic costume in fact the purple line coat
that he wears throughout the entire movie is meant
to be exactly like his comics costume he wears
the backstory at the beginning of the movie with
him being born with this rare genetic condition is
similar to his comics backstory he was born with
a condition that he tried to cure through science
leading to him becoming the morbius character
they changed a few minor details like he did
originally grow up on greece he did become a
scientist but it's his backstory with the matt
smith milo character the lucious locious crown
character that's different matt smith is playing
a character called lucian he changes his name
to milo because every kid that's moved in next
to him and died a quick death he's renamed to milo
because they die so quickly so matt smith is like
a changed version of hunger with the same powers
as morbius jared harris is playing a version of
the emile nicholas character in the comics in
his backstory originally he's the character
that morbius accidentally winds up killing on the
boat when he becomes morbius for the first time
in the movie it winds up being matt smith's hunger
character that winds up killing him the whole
backstory about him combining vampire bat dna to
get his powers is similar to the comics there's no
shock therapy in there in the original story there
was a lot of electroshock therapy as part of that
there was no original vampire bat that's why
a lot of his powers are very different from
traditional vampire powers and traditional
vampire weaknesses he appeared for the first time
in spider-man comics around the time spider-man
was getting mutated again getting those six arms
another really cool connection to spider-man no
way home is that when the purple tears in reality
appear at the end of that movie and all the
classic versions of the multiverse sinister six
villains start showing up one of the multiverse
characters is that six-armed version of spider-man
as far as i know though he did not come from the
venom universe he just came from another random
universe and if it wasn't clear the director
did clarify a bunch of plot points in the movie
days before the movie actually came out which
was kind of funny he said the events of the
morbius movie do take place in the same universe
as the venom movies so this does take place after
the events of venom lithium carnage they directly
referenced it during the movie his character did
grow up to be a scientist in the comics going to
college in the united states but he never worked
for horizon labs in the comics like he does during
the movie horizon labs does show up a lot in the
more recent spider-man comics spider-man worked
there briefly and they were eventually absorbed
into alcomax most people know that corporation
as the evil futuristic corporation from the
spider-man 2099 comics which will appear during
spider-man across the spider-verse along with
oscar isaac also mcu moon knight in his spider-man
2099 futuristic version of nueva york i guess you
could call spider-man 2099 in spider-man across
the spider-verse a variant of mcu moon knight
technically that would make sense we meet martine
bancroft for the first time who is morbius's love
interest in the comics after he goes to college in
the movie she starts out as one of his co-workers
another doctor working at horizon labs working on
their projects she eventually winds up learning
what morbius is doing with the vampire bats and
just like in the comics martine does wind up
getting the same powers that he does so she'll
come back the next time they do a sequel movie
or when they do a big sinister six crossover
movie with morbius in it she whips out the first
daily bugle edition of the movie there's at least
three or four during the movie and the different
versions all reference different spider-man easter
eggs the daily bugle logo that they used in the
movie is from the tobey maguire spider-man movies
so that means that this universe's version of jay
jonah jameson also works at this print edition of
the daily bugle because this is present day they
also probably have an online broadcast news source
too just like the mcu version of j jonah jameson
the daily bugle does kind of wind up being our
first legit spider-man easter egg though they
removed a ton of them that were in the trailer
so far so i'll explain the ones they removed and
why they probably did that the movie did not have
the scene of the tobey maguire spider-man costume
with him walking by it on the wall with the tom
holland mcu murder plot points from the mysterio
storyline on top of it they removed a shot of
a bus with an ad for spider-man on it there was
a daily bugle ad that was running supposed to say
where is spider-man as if he disappeared recently
there's no truck mentioning craven on the side
there was going to be a pastry truck that was
run by craven's family that would appear during
the film even though now sony is filming a craven
movie with aaron taylor johnson that's right mca
quicksilver is the new sony craven so post all
your multiverse variant memes they never mention
oscorp in the movie like they do in the trailers
that was actually in andrew garfield's amazing
spider-man easter egg it was going to be his
version of the logo in the movie tyrese is playing
a character from the comics called simon stroud
just like the comic book version he's an fbi agent
on a special task force that hunts supernatural
creatures in spider-man villains but in the movie
he tells morbius that the artificial blood that
he created earlier had saved his life during
the war in afghanistan the artificial arm that
they never call out during the film was supposed
to have been created by ozcorp it shows up a lot
more during the trailer shots and even though
mcu vulture did get transported to the venom
universe in the movie during the post-credits
scene originally he was going to be a bigger
part of the third act of the movie when morbius
gets arrested and then busts out a prison but a
couple versions of their daily bugle throughout
the movie mention different spider-man villains
so one mentions rhino and black cat who which will
show up during the future sinister six movies and
spin-offs another one mentions the chameleon
who will also show up during the craven movie
that they're filming right now so some of those
spider-man easter eggs setting up other movies
did survive they explained that this version
of milo comes from a rich family and owns this
version of horizon labs he suffers from the same
condition as morbius so he's been funding his
research all these years as they're looking for
this cure on the dl the boat that they wind up
chartering for morbius when he gets his powers
is right out of the comics but the boat in the
movie is called the myrnow which is a reference to
the classic german film director f.w murnau most
famous for directing nosferatu the 1922 adaptation
of bram stoker's dracula a lot of you've also seen
the meta easter egg here too so fun sinister
six spider man no way home connection in this
willem dafoe who played the tobey maguire green
goblin also once played a version of max shrek in
a retelling of that original murnau story also
starring john malkovich in that same movie who
played a version of the director fw murnow john
malkovich was also supposed to play the vulture
in tobey maguire spider man 4 when they were still
going to make that movie the easter eggs have come
full circle just like in the comics on the boat
he winds up killing everyone except for martine
because he doesn't want to hurt her the only
difference there is that jared harris's character
was there in the comics and he wound up killing
him instead of the hunger character which is the
way it went down in the movie when tyrese's fbi
task force investigates the accident later on the
boat they mentioned it's just like the incident
in san francisco that is a reference directly
to the events of venom lithium carnage like i
said they're taking place in the same universe
in the trailer when he takes down the thugs and
sets out that underground lab later in the movie
in the trailers he tells them i am venom using
his traditional catchphrase but that catchphrase
didn't appear in the actual movie when jared
harris's character comes to visit matt smith's
milo after the accident happens he tells him on
a scale from one to ten his pain is 11. that's a
reference to doctor who matt smith most known for
playing the 11th version of the doctor i actually
did videos for every single matt smith doctor who
episode on my channel a long time ago you can find
them if you go to my channel and search for doctor
who emergency awesome all the different powers
that morbius gets are right out of the comics the
only minor difference that some of you have asked
about who watched that 90s animated spider-man
series which is a classic it's a great tv series
is that in the comics originally he always drank
blood like a regular vampire when they made that
90s animated series the sensors wouldn't allow
him to drink blood on screen because little kids
were watching the show so they made it so that the
tv version only sucked out the plasma from people
using the hand suckers that's where the hand
suckers came from just from the tv show but in the
movie that was the whole reason why they had the
character create the artificial blood so that he
seemed like less of a villain like oh i'm trying
to survive on this artificial blood but it's also
why that was diminishing return so eventually
he would always have to drink human blood he
explains that animal blood won't work in natural
human blood will make him stronger than artificial
blood it lasts longer in his system but it also
makes him more aggressive kind of like hunger's
character which is why he tries to avoid it as
much as possible he doesn't gain the ability to
control bats but apparently bats do think of him
as one of their own and help him when he asks for
their help which is why they attack hunger at the
end of the movie he has super speed regeneration
echolocation he has a measure of super sight he
can fly but one of his major weaknesses is that
when he does run low on blood he does start to
revert back to the weakened state he was in before
the experiment matt smith's hunger character takes
one of the spare treatments he created in secret
then kills their nurse at horizon blaming morbius
incorrectly a version of that actually happened in
the comics but it was martine bancroft that got
blamed by simon stroud and then arrested wrongly
when they're interrogating him they make a
bunch of vampire and pop culture references
dracula references like i said minor connection to
mcu blade mcu dracula moon knight the supernatural
characters that marvel is doing right now in the
trailers morbius also makes some lost boys jokes
that movie was about a group of vampires but
they cut that scene from the final movie the
reason why holy water doesn't work on him is
because he doesn't have any of the traditional
weaknesses that classic vampires have when he's in
prison originally what was supposed to happen is
he was going to cross paths with mcu vulture who
had already been transported from the mcu if you
remember the voiceover in the trailers vulture
was supposed to encourage him to give into his
baser instincts and break out of prison and the
vulture was going to use that as an opportunity
to break out but they obviously change that with
new post-credit scenes the club where hunger winds
up killing those random dudes in the third act
is also called the oriole the oriole is a marvel
character the news station that keeps broadcasting
about what happened is a version of new york one
which is an alternate universe version of the
news channel that you see in the mcu spider-man
films like spider-man no way home and spider-man
far from home at the end of the movie martine
bancroft does wind up drinking morbius's blood
turning into a living vampire just like she did
in the comics getting the same powers that he had
the only difference is that in the comics it was
another vampire who had attacked her and gave her
those powers he does wind up using the other bats
to kill matt's miss hunger character in the comics
he was never killed he just was weakened and then
escaped away but in the first post-credits scene
a purple tear appears over the sky that looks
exactly like the one at the end of spider-man no
way home and they use that to explain that mcu
vulture got transported during dr strange's second
spell i've already done a completely separate
video about all the post credit scenes so i'll
link that in the description below you can watch
that there's a lot of hand wavy logic i don't
think that the purple tears and doctor strange's
spell was supposed to work like that they use
the same bright light effect that they use when
venom was being transported between universes he
says i hope the food here is better and because
there's no record of this universe's version of
adrian tombs existing or having been arrested they
have to let mcu vulture go then in the second post
credit scene after another short time jump morbius
has apparently been contacted by this mcu vulture
who's been watching his work being a fan of his
who calls him out to this deserted area he shows
up in a new version of the mcu vulture suit
the director also talked about this after i posted
my post-credits scene video a couple days ago
the director said that he thinks that this version
of the vulture is a resourceful guy so he just
kind of implies that maybe he cobbled together a
new version of the vulture suit in this universe
even though mcu vulture is not meant to be an
electrical engineer or a mechanical engineer so
presumably he would have had to have found another
character to create a version of the vulture suit
but there's no battle of new york inside the
venom universe so there's no chitauri invasion
which means that none of his tech has chaturi
tech in it like the mcu vulture suit had in it
so like i said there's a lot of hand-waving
logic in this but he says a bunch of guys
like them should team up and take care of this
universe version of spider-man so the reason why
a lot of people are upset about this is because
they're like why would he hate spider-man because
spider-man saved his life even if he forgot peter
parker because of the effects of doctor strange's
spell he would remember a version of spider-man
saving his life at some point so we'll see
whatever their logic is once they do a sinister
six spin-off film but clearly mcu vulture is meant
to be on that team along with morbius probably
venom 2 probably version of craven in all the
other big sinister six villains they're doing
spin-off movies for in the next couple of years
as far as the version of spider-man that exists
in this universe it's either going to wind up
being tobey maguire andrew garfield or maybe
even a live-action version of miles morales
right now i would love if it were andrew garfield
because so much of his amazing spider-man 2
featured morbius easter eggs venom symbiote saga
easter eggs they were going to do a version of all
this stuff that they're doing now back during the
amazing spider-man 2 era but if you spotted any
other big spider-man easter eggs in the movie
that i didn't talk about during the video just
write them below in the comments everyone click
here for my brand new doctor strange 2 trailer
video with new footage and click here for my
brand new moon knight episode 2 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!